are you guys doing today each other
again but yeah a lot of people probably
don't realize that you haven't seen each
other in a little while so it's like you
you know at the con you actually get to
hang out again definitely say things
that are inappropriate good being
serious were actually at WonderCon and
so I am curious for each of you if you I
don't know if you have the time to walk
the convention floor but is there
something that you collect that you
actually want to go shopping for here
there's some really cool stuff
downstairs it's cool there's a lot of
people dressed up I really want to go
all the people and everything like that
just just experience it it's like
meeting meeting one of your favorite
characters in real life named Cleo from
holes and I love anime so I'm probably
gonna see some shounen jump something
because that's what I was looking for a
convener ooh tone oh I'm sure it's there
yeah I was just gonna say that this year
I walked around a little bit and I'm
really blown away by the level of
cosplay this year sometimes it's like
really prevalent prevalent and sometimes
it's like a little less but I will tell
you that I really recommend if you have
the time go around downstairs it's like
it's really crazy though I've seen a lot
of my hero oh yes
no Hulu doesn't have the first 13
episodes of my hair but sorry that the
class people that don't realize now the
real question for that show my hero
academia is are you watching it in
Japanese with English subtitles or do
you watch it in English I mean do you
watch this which one yes
subtitle 'some yes show but I think if
it sounds really cheesy or on the nose I
do not like to watch shows or movies
that are translated like I want I wanted
subtitles yeah usually but you know
something I see the I see the pros and
cons of doing it either way because if
you watch it in Japanese you're hearing
what the director the way the dialogue
is the way the inflection is with the
words but at the same time you're
reading such like it's there's pros and
cons it's crazy to think about that for
a deadly class there's some like we were
talking about this like there's there's
an actual Russian Victor out there and
there's like like yeah like all the
seeing us from around the world and it's
like man that must be so hard to go in
on someone else's work and like give
your own interpretation in I want to
jump in to actually talk about the show
a little bit what did you learn making
the first season that if you guys are
fortunate enough to make a second season
that you want to take with you you know
what I mean physically there's that
infrastructure this is like a way when
you make a show for the first season is
a lot of like figuring out how do we
make something like this in the time
frame that were allotted how many shots
VFX can we do in one episode like you're
figuring out that infrastructure and you
know how everyone likes to work going
with my instincts like I didn't trust
them at the beginning of the season like
I was trying to maybe I don't know what
the heck but now I know that my
instincts are right and I have to follow
them so that's something I would like to
continue doing for season 2 and also
fighting skills definitely I want I want
to see it stay honest to the comics I
think it's aesthetically I would let you
know they did a lot of yellow lighting
and stuff that were it was it's like an
exact to print from the comics even
character stance and and all that so I'd
really like like to see it stayed true
to the comics I would say keeping
yourself healthy and then also having
something to do when you're when you're
on set but not working
that's what you learned yeah yeah looks
Tendo switches books and I respect you
for that because I just yeah just just I
guess I guess it's just more getting
excited for first season to to just try
and go and have as much fun as possible
and it's like anything like when you're
learning to play a sport eventually it
just becomes second nature and to just
follow your impulses and follow your but
I think a lot it's a tough question to
answer without Rick here who who is
literally like this like beacon of like
like this crazy vision for it for the
whole show and you kind of just have to
kind of have to follow him and and it's
been great and you want to as well
impulses that was something I had an
issue with too when I first started I
had a lot of trouble figuring out Willie
but I learned and I talked to miles and
Rick about it never like bring what you
bring what you got that's why we because
this show is based on a comic book and
the characters are already written like
you want to be exactly what the fans
want and what the creator of the show
who's your producer and writer and
showrunner once but then you have to
trust yourself and and think okay they
hired me for a reason so my Maria has to
be the correct Maria for the best but
you just have to stick to it and we're
actually so lucky to that we've had such
a phenomenal response from the fans that
it helps you to like okay I'm doing
something right and you can you know you
can trust that your interpretation of
the character is is great because I've
had you know just scene for all of us
nothing but but a positive reviews and
and and and people who really love these
characters that are from the comic but
aren't something completely different
now I think a lot of people don't
realize who are just watching television
or watching movies what it really takes
to make these things and the long hours
that go on and so I kind of want to
shine a light on that like talk a little
bit about for one of the episodes what's
your shooting schedule like
how brutal is it are you like 16-hour
days do you want to be there for me from
13 to 17 hour days the first two
episodes after the pilot I would say
were the hardest issues were blocked
shooting so that means we're shooting
two different episodes at the same time
by the end of the week you're shooting
into Saturday yeah and you get home with
like 7:00 a.m. Saturday
so you start at the crack of dawn on
Monday and we have like fighting
rehearsals in between takes so free time
like we don't really know what that is
that's pretty much thanks that's pretty
much what we're here to do and I
remember some people asking you should
go check this out you should go check
that out I remember when we had some off
time men and I would just like play
spider-man oh yeah that was my roommate
too by the way great guy you know very
considerate have a good time but no but
I think that uh you know from the
outside everyone looks at it as a I mean
listen it's it's really cool to be on I
can only imagine what it's like being an
actor on a show like this but I just
think a lot of people there's a lot to
learn about what really goes on in
making stuff like this and what it
really pulls out of you because I think
a lot of people don't realize it's like
a marathon you know I have a good
analogy cooking hot dogs with small
skewers and then after you finally
finished cooking you eat it it takes
like two seconds but it took like ten
minutes to cook the hot dog hot dog the
fire and they weren't long enough and
they were also wooden and it was a yes
no the right hot dogs we when you think
back on the making of the show what's
like a day or two that you will always
remember about the first season whether
it be because someone
kept on blowing their line or just
because you could not hit a certain mark
or it was like it was very it's a very
casual thing I mean if any memories
would be good memories so let's flip
it's a good memory what's like the
memory that you will always look what
you know like a day or two you always
remember this is a handsome guy what are
they going to do and then he was a
sweetest guy and he had a dog and that
really messed me up because I kept
thinking of you know the actor with the
dog and then [ __ ] with the dogs and
I'm like no no no I have to rescue this
dog no no no this is fictional
right right so I remember that and then
he was a sweet guy and we open God yeah
I guess we have a look you know we also
have like a lot of memories of us just
all hanging out and going dancing Maria
taking us to go salsa dancing man we did
all night oh yeah oh so much fun yeah
I'm not saying I'm good at nothing but
we danced all night supposed to mix
Coronas and tequila yeah you are old
enough to drink in Canada he's trying to
tell me that the cast of deadly class
was actually having alcohol no this is
crazy talk yes what people participate
on on our show yeah mostly coffee a
little water but obviously you guys all
went out a few times off set what is
that like because at the time no one has
seen the show so I would imagine it
would be a little different in the
future when you roll out right here
one time Jack tried pulling that
remember yeah we went to I'm sorry you
think we're on a show and they're like
we don't care
you and Dragonball Z like new
live-action anime character you're with
that brings me to another thing
did you ever as a group just say f it
let's go out in costume and let go to a
club oh my god I have an interesting
well that wasn't in costume but yeah oh
yeah I did do that but also I remember
one time I was going home as we're
talking about earlier like long hours
and and I remember going home to my
apartment and I was like walking down
the hallway and I've had this mohawk for
a while now and and I'm walking by and
like this guy kind of does this like
like look to me and I'm like I'm like
people don't really like who's I'm like
people haven't got yes used to the
mohawk yet and then I step into the
elevator and I look there's like all
mirrors and my face is just completely
bruised and like bloody because I didn't
take off my makeup is decide to go home
so this guy just thought I got like the
[ __ ] beat out of me yeah so people
actually for me I would love to go out
in public like that because you've got
experience like I've spoken like like
Nick Frost in fighting with my family
had the Mohawk and like you know looked
like this big tough dude and he went
around and he said it was awesome
everyone left me alone he like wore like
real that he got on two different films
and looked like some gangster when we
went out together like hey I had a
mohawk I were there a lot of deleted
scenes from the first season that you
remember I don't I don't quite remember
I didn't I feel like they can trace it
content it's all a blur
there's a few yeah I mean the bottom
things like that but it was all
meticulous so that the story had a great
flow and so that all the information was
given but it was buried in character so
it didn't seem like exposition very
well-written I want to see all the
outtakes one day like all the all cuz
like put up like a private youtube link
or even put up put up it's really good
they should just put it up I think the
fans would love that
did you see the blooper reel out like a
wrap party yeah yeah I would love to see
the blooper reel is it super dirty or is
it just people messing up anything
everything okay let's talk about some of
the action and filming it and how
challenging was it like talk a little
bit about like because you mentioning
like the thing is when you're filming
you have like a seven day shoot eight
day shoot you got to learn everything
during that shoot did they ever do it
I've heard from some productions where
they have they will do the action
towards the end of the week to give you
the most time to learn it and other
times you have to film it on like the
first day or second day how did that
work what's best for the production but
it was really for me was hard I did not
have any fighting training at all I
would not work out a day just because so
I had to I had to get like stronger and
like fit for the show and for Maria so
it took me awhile together it was really
challenging but then I loved it and then
you know we had amazing stunt doubles
and and coordinators and they make sure
we were safe and it looked great and
they gave us that you know energy of
wanting to do more and be better at it
so it was hard we would train in between
takes so we will we were sword all the
time and exhausting and sweaty but it
was worth it
I really loved doing action scenes now
so fun it's rewarding mm-hmm and it
shows on the show you guys did amazing
the popularity of the superhero genre
right now I thought by now they might
slow down a little bit but it's you know
each year it seems like it's getting
bigger and bigger more shows on TV for
each of you what do you think it is
about the superhero genre that resonates
with so many people well for us on our
show what I think is so cool and we
talked about this a little bit is that
our world isn't really special it's
pretty much the world as it is with an
edge it's not the human condition right
and it's literally human because no one
has powers no one has anything but skill
it's kind of like an antihero yeah it's
a story about the villains and I think
that the fact that it's about villains
and not supervillains makes the human a
little bit more it's easier to see you
know and our show isn't really a
superhero show but it's close to the
genre because it's a graphic novel and I
think that that helps us get a lot of
fans but I think people might forget
that like nobody has superpowers and
it's really cool the superpower is like
the the level of intellect that goes
into the writing it's like yeah this
makes us all look like we're geniuses I
have what we call a few fun questions I
want to find my piece of paper that
hopefully you'll find them a little fun
I was looking I know you were I thought
you for each of you what TV show would
you love to guest star on good question
oh it can be an older show yeah okay no
that was broad City Seinfeld
maybe Bates Motel friends
[Laughter]
that's hard that's so hard I'm blanking
oh man not me there's got to be like an
all-time favorite that I'm missing
Oh be like one of wills friends like yo
for each of you
first do you remember your first movie
or TV show crush bear for me very quick
I like it that's like oh wow
same actually I change my answer I like
Jesse McCartney but he was only acted a
little bit I don't know if that counts
for me with Sandra Bullock yeah man I've
always been attracted to 12 by the way
no wrong answers what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once yeah you guys are way faster ooh
toe Shippuden I've seen Breaking Bad a
few times
Simpsons South Park Rick and Morty Ricky
morning yeah I've actually watched Star
Trek The Next Generation way more than
once I'm a big fan of that and no but
I've just got a little Klingon no you
know what's funny I haven't seen the new
show yet but next generation is it's
just it's it's very well done and I like
that it deals with you know what's going
on in society and a sci-fi kind of vibe
you know it's very good in case you
haven't seen it
keep it in eyes no and why wouldn't you
love it that's the real thing do you
guys collect anything what do you
collect
I collect fan letters actually I don't
have some all over my wall at both my
places they're just really sweet
sometimes they send me little sometimes
they'll send me currency for stamps so I
collect the it'll only take a couple
dollars of each currency but yeah I have
from all around the world I love it do
you guys collect nah after watching that
show about you know tidying up your
plays and things that bring you joy and
Spike Leroy and I'm like yeah buh-bye
you're going to trash so no I'm
technically I collect video games
because I play them by the way it's
totally valid I know people that collect
video games have like having all the
different ones no like I'm talking like
they have like like the Nintendo and the
Sega Genesis and like you know all the
systems yeah oh yeah I used to collect a
lot of stuff but I've tried to get
better and I try to always remind myself
that line from Fight Club which is the
things you own end up owning you
by the way Fight Club is amazing but and
by the way there's nothing wrong with
collecting stuff it's just you'll see it
just it takes up a lot of space you're
really flipping this thing on me I'm not
usually the one answering questions no
no I think that it's very I think
screaming is amazing and I think that
you love video games and what's
happening is apples coming out with like
a streaming thing like Apple video
arcades and I think that Xbox and ps4
are gonna come out with a streaming
version it's gonna be less where you own
consoles and just own the joystick and
everything will be rendered in the cloud
that's what's coming it's streaming
video game
Wow so I learned a lot when I was at
Apple last week I think we just realized
a lot of one thing that we collect is
it's actually online but a lot of the
fan art that we get tagged in we all
have folders and we save the fan art or
repost it because it's incredible the
amount of wood
that's the thing actually about being at
WonderCon is you actually these are some
of the most passionate people that watch
the show so it has to be crazy for you
guys like to meet people that really
genuinely love all the hard work you put
in and it really means something to them
look have you met any fans that have
really like you've you know I can see
you're getting like you know what I mean
like but if you met a few people that
you're like like you're gonna like you
know cry because it's like you know what
I mean someone got a tattoo you know
SIA and the phrase that but yeah yeah we
all came up with that what someone got a
tattooed on them yeah so it's really
amazing and you feel like the
responsibility to do a good job you know
for them completely yeah jumping back
into my quote unquote fun questions you
guys have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy
film Blade Runner war the worlds these
all count oh you love do you mean the
movie that everybody in Hollywood is in
it's like crazy that cast for the new
day almost everybody yeah that's true
that's very true what you say but it
does have a that Denis guy who's
directing it Bazin yeah he's what we
call talented I'm gonna use that term I
really like Tron the movie didn't do
well but it has a special place in my
heart because look how it look and
listen to how I sound it's great trans
phenomenal one of my all-time favorite
films seriously the original or the the
original one oh I like that one
oh no the soundtrack of legacies a whole
nother life no no no that's a whole
nother level but I had the original rock
my world it's great rock my world so
this is these are these are some
questions that are called this or that
so it's just like basically which do you
prefer
Star Wars or Star Trek again no wrong
answer
game this one's a little tougher Game of
Thrones are Breaking Bad Wow I've only
seen a very little bit of it so like I
guess my opinion is bias I've seen no I
just I've never you know I've done these
these questions at least two or three
times I've never seen everyone be like
on all Breaking Bad like do we have all
of you said Breaking Bad that's the
advantage of being the host
you know the moderator if you will it
can go either way
how are you saying I'm not on Game of
Thrones that was so quick
han Solo or Indiana Jones I was just at
Disneyland and experienced both brought
back some good right and again we are
very close to Disneyland it's literally
across the street I've been asking this
of everyone who's been coming through
favorite ride at Disneyland does
calculate the California Park it all
counts both the Florida
Oh incredible yeah yeah Space Mountain
smells great a lot of you know what I
even know what I missed the most at
Disneyland they used to have this really
cool arcade upstairs from Space Mountain
up this like yes you do and it was like
you took this slow ass elevator
escalator upstairs in the ED like a ton
of pinball machines and all these arcade
games and and because I love Tron so
much I love those arcades and they took
it out and it totally angered me it was
amazing huge Arcada Disneyland it was
like right next to Space Mountain
upstairs yeah I think space itself
there's just empty you know exactly what
you're talking about
exactly god I forgot that was there we
were we were looking up at it and we
were like what I was what used to be
there I'm because I remember going up
there but I couldn't remember what it
was it was a on that note I need to stop
with you guys I'm gonna say and I mean
this sincerely thank you so much for
indulging me with these stupid fun
questions I really appreciate it but
mostly I really hope that you guys get
to make a season 2 and it's like
sincerely and enjoy WonderCon and please
walk the convention floor like take it
in a little bit